Twilight Patrol at the U.S border wall
where Arizona meets Mexico
for one deputy sheriff the late shifts
about to get busy
[Music]
undocumented aliens that are over here
on the West side we joined Deputy Cody
essary as he responded to a sighting of
illegal immigrants
until we make it over there
the scar the undergrowth by Highway 92.
do they have eyes on them right now okay
it's a well-known pickup point for
people directed here by the Mexican
cartels they pay for Passage
head right up here
hang out right here real quick
border patrols report a huge increase in
illegal traffic over the past 18 months
human and narcotic
on this occasion Cody and his colleagues
find what they're looking for three
people are hiding in the darkness
dressed in camouflage wearing specially
made shoes with soles of carpet they
have the the carpet pattern on the
bottom it just keeps their shoes from
making an imprints in the sand
border security is clearly a big issue
here at these elections and it feeds
into vorto's priorities Nationwide
priorities that include the power of the
vote itself
a woman who is bold who is fierce who is
compassionate and very loving Kerry Lake
in Arizona Carrie lake is the Republican
candidate for governor Trump endorsed
on stage the discourse is every inch the
Donald fake news the fake news fake news
and the fake news
as governor in her State she would
certify or not the results of the next
presidential election lake is a trump
loyalist who says he was cheated in the
last one she won't fully endorse the
very election that she's standing in
next Tuesday we got the fake news in
full force is the only what the election
that you will endorse an election that
you win you mean will I accept the
results if you win is that the only way
you will endorse this election I will
absolutely accept the results of a fair
honest and transparent election 100 but
your opponents say that you embody a
threat to democracy your opponents say
that your body are threat to democracy
you talk about a BS story
sorry it's an election denial the
biggest BS story of all do you think
election denial is dividing the country
is election denial dividing the country
in Arizona they remember the days before
democracy take a trip in the wild west
through the Apache Pass and you arrive
at Fort Bowie where Apache tribes fought
the U.S army among those captured here
in 1886 was the warrior Geronimo
the story told is of a corner of America
shaped by Bloody conflict
it's a tale reworked as a warning by
democrats that embedding election
deniers in the voting process threatens
democracy and violence unfortunately
violence is a possibility here I don't
think it's a probability at least I have
enough faith in this country and our
countrymen to think that it's not but we
have to be prepared for any outcome and
that's worrisome
they've known trouble Once Upon a Time
in the West they fear it again
James Matthews of Sky News in Arizona